おっん
ん
th
もう
名それだけで今日はですね
寝起きでちょっとは避けないんですけど3 day
ん
ご当選おめでとうございますうぇいそうです何とですねぼくねー
何が応募したら当たりました
んだ
we are
ん
par
やばいお
これですね appbank さんという好
なんていうんでしょ afuri アプリとか
ちょっとなんかこう iphone の何かおこうね
いろいろこうやっちゃう人たちで人たちだけそういうお店がありまして
そちらのサイト言えなんかチャンネルがあって
今曲ですねでできないんですけど2戦がありまして
5名様にしか当たらなくてこの日パパ23
うんこうもう本当に僕のため吸っていいと思う
ほんとんです下スター姉ばが23石すごい好きなんで
応募したんですよこっ3
誰にも言わずに
そしたらごめんのうちに当たっちゃって
今こうやって兄貴が送られてきたんですよねー
それをなんかアップ安価なチャンネルのまみり村さんっていう人がすごい美人だけど
ちょっと可愛らしたかって
ちょっと嬉しかったですはいというわけですね
まぁちょっと今日はちょっと軽くいきますよというわけでアルパカにいさんがもらえた
という動画でしたーー
えっと
今7月の6日なんですけど
ちょっと今から
東京に行ってくるねーなーっ